yeah i just i just thought it was a line
on the ground
back and forth
[Laughter]
interrupting this video for super
important announcement i'll be quick
but this is very important listen up
g-fuel
has their biggest offer of the year the
year year
year year year for an entire week
straight until the 30th
of november g fuel tubs are buy one
get one that's right 100 sale
mix and match any flavors you want i
recommend getting the pewdiepie flavor
it's legit i love it i don't i drink it
every single day
lately i've been trying out the peach
cobbler and sonic rings they're
delicious
that's the fun about g fuel there's so
many great flavors stay hydrated
stay energized now is the time to try it
if you haven't already
and also a great time to stock up the
limit is 10 tubs per order
so go nudge you don't have to add code
pewdiepie at checkout
but if you want to be extra hardcore you
can of course do it so yeah that's it
g fuel check it out link is the
description great time to save some
money
on with the video
[Music]
let's go have fun don't die don't get
mad
oh i'm the imposter okay nice
it was imposter hey if i hear peter's
voice i'm out of here
pj's imposter speed run
ah the [ __ ] is that mumbling
dude that's just corpse's voice oh my
bad
just heard grunting oh no that was me
that was me
nice nice you guys have this one too
nice yeah
no i don't i'm just escorting you guys
to be honest all right
i'll keep grunting let's do this
that's like some weird grudge noise
oh no he's dead oh that sucks
i was doing that to my friends in
phasmophobia just go beyond them
your voice works perfectly for that
because the challenges that we have to
find are tasks that's where the fun is
you know what i mean
oh i can't i can't fix it even if i
tried
oh my god it wasn't worth it huh
it was worth it i i didn't die i don't
care it's all good
okay just scream if you see him okay i
hear dave where's dave
dave davis dave are you out
oh there what up corpsey
oh you know just exploring nice
that's what about you just looking at
the scenery you know
of space yeah i didn't actually know you
could do this yeah i didn't know you
could go this far right
[Laughter]
a whole new world
it's nice what the [ __ ]
they'll never find me here oh
no good job pj
you did it you get to keep the crap can
i polish it for you okay
[Music]
i'm the imposter no no
oh my god good luck
of course
okay sorry i i didn't mean to throw it
under the bus i i i
dipped who's impossible
run
oh i'm gonna
am i safe oh my god he killed nogla
i can't believe it all right
gotta make sure i check my peripherals i
don't remember my
oh jesus okay how are we supposed to
leave the car
she can hear us he
hey okay we're good we're good everyone
[Music]
i'm leaving
oh jesus peter you're green don't be
that color
okay we can talk here these are uh
soundproof walls this is a soundproof
room
yeah thank god okay okay if we see him
i run left pg run right corps
circulate wait wait wait guys wait wait
is anyone there
[Music]
spooked my spooks off huh there you are
we got a couple just gotta do this very
quietly
nice two more oh god
it's spedicy oh who's there
who goes there
okay okay okay one more test
i just got this is my last task
this is the last one okay okay thanks
thanks guys i'm good
i gotta get to the laboratory all right
will you skirt me i have met skin
oh perfect let's go baby oh god was that
there before
okay cool
[Music]
where the hell are they okay this is my
last one
bang okay i'm good i'm good thanks
thanks
oh god she will just hide here
what if because i'm done with my tasks
okay i know a great hiding spot follow
me
up here they'll never expect it hide
behind there we go
this is perfect you put the kid out
there like watching
so who's dad not doing the task hey
ghosts do your g
i kind of want to go with them like what
oh wait wait if one of us dies we lose
though right
no two can be aligned okay you can i'll
run
at him and then we all split that one
that's a great idea let's do that yeah
what the [ __ ] comes now now now what are
you doing
oh god what happened are you courses
that was it wasn't it holy [ __ ] did he
just run past me
which way did it go oh god okay we're
good wait you're alive
i'm alive i don't know okay
who hasn't done their [ __ ] task
ghosts
my dick i haunted you last time it was
pretty epic
where are you really where are you
we need to make like uh calls if they're
close
hey no no no no no no
you just survived and you didn't even
know it
are you sleeping for my child no you're
done
you're done all right here we go there
we go two children my
children are sims for your children and
i'm a sim for you that's how it works
i'm i'm just raising a family of sims
i'm trying to teach them how to sing
a family of sims you mean the simpsons
yes exactly
thanks for laughing at that pretty joke
i appreciate it
i have family
[Music]
died
listen you don't have to do this
i have a child you do have two jails i
have
two child like i forgot about it but hey
listen
i'll just stay here and you just walk
away
you know i won't tell i won't tell
anyone i won't tell anyone
i swear all right i'll be back in in a
few minutes
still here okay i will be of course
thank you thank you so much i i won't
forget this
okay i'll stay i'll say it'll stick
oh i'm a good boy okay
now what's happening here yeah
corpse dead oh don't just run by here at
all
no i i didn't go anywhere i just stayed
here like i promised
just been here i was just asking if you
saw jonas anywhere oh no i i
haven't seen anyone oh jonas is central
get him run run run central okay okay
thanks
oh he's southwest now south face
betrayal
how the hell did you not die right here
that's
great that's crazy i did not write
everyone out
oh
let's get there jayden they're here
they're here
i gotta follow the babies this way this
way
here david's this
oh yeah i gotta do my test okay i
haven't found anyone
oh here janice [ __ ] traitor what's
wrong with you
i'm not traitor why are you running with
her then
i'm not running yeah oh no
oh man all right sucks
all right i'll find more i think kiss
everyone
is anyone there guys i need help
i need help i just banded the [ __ ] out
of hidden i was in the bathrooms on top
right
and i kept opening the door to specimen
so that she would think someone went to
the specimen
get him
you're the one with the last ass oh
really
okay okay okay sh i'll do the last task
we'll bait the baiter
because i'm the masturbator yes i should
i
see you beat me to that joke that one
wasn't as funny because i expected that
i can't expect okay fair for the last
two alive like
choose to kill one of us oh okay okay
okay okay this is the last one
i just gotta download 14 28 42
56 yes 75. we're gonna win
i have no friends left oh my gosh
you are testing boundaries of friendship
i'm sorry
we won i carried you girl you should
thank me
it's me oh roomie
yes roomy i wasn't sure who that was for
saying yeah
i'm still here it's not a problem where
are you oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're safe it's all good i locked it i
locked the door guys
it's no problem the door's open i
got the key oh anybody want uh some left
over
oh hell yeah it tastes good let me slope
on that
pizza or a red egg
i got killed over a red egg pizza
god damn it hey felix yo do you think
when dave dies he goes to the daveyard
am i muted no sorry i forgot to lie
okay yeah simon says it's a tricky one
anyway see you later okay bye
oh did hell yeah dude
i'm the imposter
pj again no all right don't kill me
pj we got a deal right um
dude just give us five seconds pj
because this is very big
he's got a child pj he's got a child
it's not fair
oh god you're gonna give us away because
of sports
i [ __ ] love the raiders
what is happening here being the first
kill kind of feels hey guys
what's up i just killed growing up is
that okay
we are so beautiful he didn't see us
because we're a tree like
yeah do you see your kid throwing his
head against the wall like that huge
kids is having a tantrum right now wait
i don't even see my child where is he
my child is not crying i'll have to
reprimand him definitely crying
no he's not a little [ __ ] i changed my
mind hey man
what's up kill him which way are you
gonna go
yeah yeah you guys are going to come out
eventually
i know
let's all stack whichever happens
happens okay
pretend i'm pretending
no no you gotta oh we gotta wait let go
yeah first time huh
no my mouse i have uh
i've never lived an entire round yet
except the one where i was imposter it's
pretty cool
okay i'm back
okay i'm done nice no
no that's my joke who's imposter
let's go it's me
you're all gonna die run i didn't
realize how
little the impostor can see jaden where
are you next to me
what are you doing excuse pewds you
won't kill me right because we're on the
same goal
okay help me then just gotta kill jaden
sorry all right
i'll be your eyes i'll be your host okay
all right
let's clear up one hallway at a time
let's
first all right you check upstairs
there's no one here there's no one here
there's no one here
you just go wherever and i'll keep an
eye out okay this guy they got to be up
here right
i know oh no no no no
oh you boys better run imagine that on
his gravestone oh no no no no no no no
no no last words
yeah roomies on the left side here okay
far left side
far left side we're both
i'm paying him no you're a race trader
now i have to kill you i heard corpse as
well politically incorrect
that's not of course no don't let me do
this
don't get caught he's telling me not to
kill you
oh dave where's dave where'd he go
don't kill jack don't kill jack okay
stop telling me not to kill people
i need you to tell me where they are
you're not helping me okay i'll help you
but i have to do my task i can't be a
complete trader
so whenever i listen i'm gonna i'm gonna
kill i'm gonna
useless absolutely useless
where the [ __ ] is felix let's
settle this like men where the [ __ ] are
you i'm here
huh okay so what do you want to tell me
i want to tell you that yeah
if you follow me yeah like all the way
over here
yeah all the way into here yeah all the
way up here
where you go why are you running why are
you running
you can't zigzag your way out of this
one
you can't exactly
i have not gone to cafeteria yet ah
[ __ ] you
apologize apologize whoever apologizes
first gets to live
what did i do what am i apologizing for
just say sorry i'm sorry for
at least you'll die together
damn
i appreciated that jack that was
incredible
oh yeah okay oh oh oh oh oh oh
got it wait who's in i think i know who
it is
i'm sorry about life's thing
now you actually do have to say sorry
for something
he sends out sonar with his egg oh god
oh my god
yeah i'm doing the water task please
think of the flowers they will rot if i
don't do this
it's gonna be really bad for the flowers
i'm so sorry
the flowers go back to cafeteria
in the cafeteria philly's so serious
he's very moist
smart move hey how you doing felix i'm
i'm good
thank you okay corpse is that reactor
okay let's go there
no no jack what are you doing
i let you live wait okay okay i met you
say you're sorry i like you guys have an
honorable death together
i'm not your son and i'm never gonna
apologize
for what i'm stacking with right now
okay let the odds let the odds be in
your favor jake i'm irish i'm super
lucky i would never die in this okay
he's right
thank you corpse
god damn it [ __ ] jack
and he's plus 10 likes you've been cast
guys i think corpse might be the kill
what the [ __ ] give me
looking for some high level gaming gear
check out face
okay but of what top scientists have
determined
that wearing base gear makes you a
better gamer with at least
two percent basis for everyone no matter
what level you're at
but you need to be at least six eight to
order which i am
for you have before december 11th to
place your order
and solidify your place in the gaming
history books so what are you waiting
for
buff up your wardrobe today and head
over to base.gg
basil i'm 68 i swear
can i order